all right scream review was done we move
on to the second review of this
halloween movie extravaganza and for
those of you who are hoping i would be
werewolf jeremy
for all the reviews well that was the
plan but i never owned contacts before
so i kept the contact lenses
in the cases that they came in which had
a liquid in there
um but it wasn't sealed and so there was
this film
on top of the liquid anyhow as much as i
want pink eye
i just went ahead and i ordered another
pair of contact lenses so when they
arrive werewolf me shall return however
in the meantime let's review a movie
from 2001 that 2001 jeremy
really loved but i i watched it again
recently and uh
uh-huh yeah
hell yeah
[Music]
13 ghosts so 13 ghost was a movie from
2001 that was a remake of a movie from
1960. it star's tony shalhoub he's this
widower and he has this
distant relative who's this really
eccentric guy he's been gathering ghosts
so this guy
dies and he's like hey in my will i
leave you this
crazy house i say crazy house not as an
oh crazy house i kind of want it because
everyone in the movie
is gushing over this house this place is
awesome now i know i'm dreaming even
when i saw this movie back in 2001 i was
like
but that house though would i really
want it i'm just sitting there like i
don't know i
i kind of like a cozy house i'm all down
for modern a modern cozy house
perfect but this isn't modern i think
the actual layout and design is
[ __ ] i think that's what it is
it's just it's so
industrial it feels like you're in a
machine which they essentially are but
it's not supposed to feel that way it
it doesn't make it scary and i don't
know if the movie's secretly trying to
be
brilliant with that because the house is
a perfect metaphor
for this movie itself it's big it's
superfluous it's loud
it's filled with a bunch of ghosts but
no real
soul you see anything that helps make
scary movies scary
is the fact that it takes place in a
familiar environment houses apartments
hotels
dingy attics and basements these are all
familiar things in the world
familiarity's the key to making that
work there's nothing
familiar about the house in 13 ghosts
i've never been in a house like it i've
never seen a house remotely like it so
as long as i stay away from houses
that can only be described as 2001
glass wall [ __ ] i'll be good so at
that point i think well maybe they're
not going for scary maybe they're going
for
stylish you know stylistic and that
works
until you see things that clearly are
meant to be scary the movie fails at
being scary in the scenes it's trying to
be scary and when the movie's trying to
be stylistic
oh boy it's just heavily edited and
obnoxious when the [ __ ] hits the fan
the editing is so jumbled
you just you can't appreciate it at all
the movie relies on
kind of sound effects with really jumpy
shoddy editing and that's supposed to
make you feel the intensity and the fear
of the ghost but it's not
it's just annoying it's just sensory
overload to distract you from the fact
that
really the movie doesn't have much going
on i will say the creature designs are
actually really cool but they wanted
these 13 ghosts to have different
personalities
but they really don't other than the
jackal the jackal is actually the most
intense ghost and he's the one that
feels
significantly different from the other
ones he definitely feels really pissed
off all the time
rest of the ghosts they could be
interchangeable except for the fact that
they
look fundamentally different my favorite
part is when tony shalhoub's son is
missing in this weird environment this
weird house they're they're unfamiliar
with it and tony chalups like
we gotta find the kid i was like oh
really dad of the year the kid that
would be your son
who's lost in this strange environment
and might very well be in mortal peril
sure it's just weird i'm not saying a
dad
can't refer to their son as the kid i'm
just saying he's pretty callous given
the situation
this was a murder mystery i'd be like he
did it i thought this movie was so
kick-ass
back in the day now not gonna remember
it in t-minus one day
yeah i've already forgot i think i'm
being generous with this one but what
can i say
i got my friend right here making it
better except there's actually this one
on screen death it's a pretty sweet one
and mortal kombat 11 definitely pulled
from this movie i mean i don't know
about definitely but if i had to bet
yeah all right so 13 ghosts have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you